ما قد يبدو للوهله الاولى مشهدا في فيلم
هوليوودي هو في حقيقته واقع العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف تحترق وتنقسم بين نخب تريد
تقاربا اكبر مع الغرب والاتحاد الاوروبي
واخرى ترى ان ثمه مدارا وحيدا تدور فيه
البلاد وهو موسكو تشتبك المعارضه مع قوات
الامن تطالب باقاله الحكومه واجراء
انتخابات مبكره فيقع قتلى وجرحى وتتحول
ساحات كيف الى مختبر ل
وتوجه البلاد في المستقبل بل لهويتها ايضا
شراره الاحداث بدات في نوفمبر الماضي ان
ذاك تخلت حكومه فيكتور يانكوفيتش عن اتفاق
تجاري مع الاتحاد الاوروبي واستعاضت عنه
بمساعدات روسيه تطورت الاحداث منذ ذلك
الوقت لتشهد العاصمه كيف عشرات الالاف من
المتظاهرين في الساحات وامام مقر الحكومه
والبرلمان الى ان وصل دخان حرائقها الى
سويسرا هناك وتحديدا في جنيف يشتبك الروس
مع الامريكيين في الملف السوري وهناك
وتحديدا من دافوس يجدها نائب رئيس الوزراء
الروسي فرصه لدعوه الاوكرانيين للحوار
ومطالبه الغرب بعدم التدخل امر يكرره رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني من سويسرا ايضا فلا
شرعيه دستوريه كما قال لانذار المعارضه
لحكومته بالدعوه لانتخابات مبكره انهم
ارهابيون وسيعاقب على تصرفاتهم التي وصفها
بال ارهابيه رسائل تبعث الى خارج الحدود
ربما وتحديدا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي
ندد بقمع المتظاهرين ولامر الذين قالوا ان
الاحداث نجمت عن فشل
الحكومه يعود الخلاف الامريكي الروسي حول
اوكرانيا الى ما بعد تفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي دعمت واشنطن ما سمي في حينه
الثوره البرتقاليه عام 2004 طعن
المتظاهرون انذاك بفوز الرئيس فيكتور
يانكوفيتش المقرب من م
وجاء بكتور ينكو رئيسا في جوله اعاده وبدا
معه ان معسكر التقارب مع الغرب ينتصر في
اوكرانيا وتكرس مع يوليا تيموشينكو رئيسه
للوزراء لكن الامور تغيرت بعوده يانكوفيتش
الى الرئاسه مجددا موسكو كسبت بعودته لكن
الغرب لم يقر بانتصارها فالحرب سجال في
شوارع كيف وما حولها